dans le détail à présent des résultats
des différentes circonscriptions des
civils et nous allons commencer par la
première avec vos michael ennemi d'
eurobonds soit également sur ce plateau
à nicolas landry on saura vous sur
nicolas bonsoir ensemble donc nous
allons faire le point sur ses résultats
dans les yvelines la première tout
d'abord première circonscription alors
ce dimanche on joue en la senti les
répliques du séisme la république en
marche jusqu'à la première
circonscription des yvelines à droite
depuis à 1963 le territoire est sur le
point de basculer
didier peschard candidat de la
république en marche élue d'opposition à
versailles et réalisé 42,15 % il devance
le grand favori de cette élection le
candidat des républicains le versailles
et françois-xavier bellamy qui ne
totalise que 27 49 % des voix on écoute
la réaction de didier baichère c'est pas
une surprise qui est une bonne surprise
c'est le changement qui est en train de
s'opérer à versailles ce qui montre la
transformation c'est le résultat de
versailles on est au coude à coude il ya
500 voix d'écart je crois entre entre
les deux premiers
la ville change et je pense que les
progressistes les sociaux démocrates qui
sont finalement l'image des yvelines
depuis des années une droite ou des
centristes modéré je pense qu'il ya un
vrai barrage à la droite
ultra-conservatrice c'est ça le message
de ce soir didier baichère qui réalise
son plus gros score à montigny le
bretonneux 48,72 % des voix principale
surprise sur la ville de versailles le
républicain françois-xavier bellamy ne
devance finalement didier baichère que
de deux petits points ils l'emportent
39e 18% contre 37,0 9 % pour le candidat
de la république en marche un scénario
pas du tout attendu
voilà wilfried on pouvait sentir une
certaine tension ce dimanche soir à
versailles françois xavier bellamy était
persuadé de réaliser un très bon score
dans sa commune où il est adjoint au
maire en charge de l'enseignement
secondaire et supérieur de la jeunesse
et de l'emploi sur le plan électoral la
dynamique était clairement en faveur des
républicains dans la commune en avril
dernier françois fillon était arrivé
largement en tête au premier tour des
présidentielles avec près de 43% à des
suffrages malgré les affaires alors qu
emmanuel macron le totalisé que 27 % des
votes
une grosse déception donc mais pour
françoise et les bellamy rien n'est
perdu on les écoute d'abord beaucoup
d'électeurs on pensait que l'élection
était jouée d'avancé peut-être parce
qu'il le réseau mais avec des critères
des élections précédentes moi je crois
qu'effectivement cette élection allait
être difficile
je crois aussi qu elle est gagnable je
crois toujours qu'elle est gagnable on
va faire tout ce qu'il faut prendre une
semaine pour mobiliser clairement les
électeurs et pour leur montrer que d'un
côté il ya un projet il ya un projet
pour la france et un deuxième tour on a
on a eu beaucoup d'abstention à ce
premier tour cette abstention est lélio
aussi au fait que voilà beaucoup
d'électeurs se sont sentis peu concerné
par ce qui se passait on a une semaine
pour leur faire comprendre que ce qui se
passe les concerne vraiment et que c'est
leur avenir qui est en jeu c'est le
maire de versailles le député sortant un
françois de mazières qui avait adoubé en
quelque sorte françois-xavier bellamy
quelle a été sa réaction alors ce
résultat était forcément très mal vécu
par l'ancien député qui avait remporté
la circonscription en 2012 avec +2 56%
des voix
cette fois ci il avait choisi de ne pas
se représenter pour se consacrer à son
mandat de maire de versailles
l'homme politique avait donc décidé de
laisser la place à la nouvelle
génération et un françois xavier à
bellamy qui l'a soutenu tout au long de
la campagne françois de mazières était
au micro de tv fil 78
on est face à une sorte de tsunami
nationale aujourd'hui est très important
que sur la seule construction
première des yvelines on arrive tout
même avoir un candidat qui
n'appartiennent pas à cette chambre a
trouvé le fait d'avoir une chambre
trouva avait quelque chose au très
mauvais y compris pour le président
république et donc française et les
bellamy peut encore être réglés et je
pense que les gens doivent se mobiliser
pour nous nous ne voulons pas qu'il y
ait que des candidats de en marche c'est
très mauvais pour la démocratie
les autres résultats les autres
candidats sur cette première
circonscription alors derrière didier
baichère françois-xavier bellamy tous
les deux qualifiés pour le second tour
on retrouve la france insoumise
représenté par thibaut marshall qui
récoltent 8,04 % des voix le front
national de thierry perez arrivent
quatrièmes sur la circonscription avec 5
0 7%
deux points de moins qu'en 2012 mais la
contre performance est surtout à mettre
au crédit du parti socialiste qui
totalise seulement 4 64% des suffrages
alors que le ps était deuxième en 2012
avec 31% des voix au premier tour et 43
25 % au second on écoute la candidate
charlotte settini pas la même dynamique
on avait quand même un président de
gauche on sait très bien que les
personnes
vous votez
dans la continuité des présidentielles
centre sur la circonscription
à versailles à montigny ça va être très
compliqué pour parti socialiste
mais les valeurs restent cela vous savez
le parti c'est juste une étude qui
attend après quand on a des combats à
mener que ce soit sur une étiquette ou
sous une autre
les combats sont quand même là et là il
va être encore plus fort à noter
wilfried que la france insoumise le
parti socialiste et le front national
n'ont pas encore donné de consigne de
vote pour le second tour
aura-t-on le droit à une nouvelle
réplique du séisme dimanche prochain
avec la victoire de la république en
marche
didier deschamps réponse ce dimanche 18
juin dans la soirée
merci